what's going on guys the Academy Awards
the nominations came out this week and
as for usual some of them had me saying
oh they got that right and some of them
had me saying what the hell so we're at
screen junkies decided to get together
and make our own picks buckle up for
what a screen junkies for the Academy
crazy huh
so for the sake of time we decided to go
with six prestige categories besides
none of us saw any documentary shorts
was here so let's go right into the
deliberation with that's recording actor
I feel a lot of support for we Harrelson
and age 17 I think this is a really
strong field yeah because you got a
pledge on good minute I thought 10
Cloverfield Lane was a dimension him you
never seen before getting Radcliffe Andy
I know you're not sure about Daniel
Radcliffe where would you put it
I'm sure I think that's a lead
performance yeah but it's Paul Danos
journey Daniel Radcliffe just sparks him
along
so the Johnson Riley in the lobster I
know they just be really as well I can
keep my mouth it's like the rules honey
I get it but come on I got a voice
Keegan and don't think twice this was my
favorite show business sure is hard
movie of the year in terms of movies in
that genre I like it more than lala land
and yeah I'll give that to Keith I mean
one two three votes for keegan-michael
key you get behind that we had to first
remove like I feel like support of
moonlight between Ashton Sanders I
disagree I thought I think muhuali had
one of the most he was in little
stunning scenes of the year all the
moonlights cancel each other out for me
though oh my god out all the other left
wow that might have been the toughest
argument of the day now here are the
nominees for Best Supporting Actor Maher
Saleh Ali for moonlight John Goodman 10
Cloverfield Lane Woody Harrelson age of
17 keegan-michael key
don't think twice and Daniel Radcliffe
with
are me man and believe it or not my
Hershel ollie
the only carryover from the actual
nominations to the screen junkie
nomination congratulations Marshall one
of the greatest honors you'll receive
this award season now let's move on to
the other supporting category where we
go VIN to some heated deliberation
morning not for the faint of heart
it seemed to me that we all were agree
with this Viola Davis actor way into
this nomination for probably four and
Michelle Williams without that scene I
wasn't feeling well oh my gosh man the
movie no doubt from yeah yeah all right
I noticed some kind of conditional I
know they Margaret Bowman from hell or
high water she's the waitress is like
what don't you want I remember her as
where did I remember Jeff Bridges or
anyone else we always going to do a
grandma we always give it to an elderly
woman I have to be honest we're looking
at hidden figures that's a big one I
actually jumbo name is a little bit
better than Octavia Spencer this is good
yeah but I thought you know my name is
really stand out for me sounds like
Admiral things show me the Monet kind of
odd to say that we have my minutes room
I know what I do here I really love
Naomi Harrison moonlight yeah she was
just a tragic woman what about uh Morena
Baccarin from Deadpool no no and your
screen junkies nominees for Best
Supporting Actress are Margaret Bowman
hell or high water
Viola Davis spent Naomi Harris
moonlight janelle monae hidden figures
and Michelle Williams Manchester by the
sea so we have three carryovers in this
category from the actual Oscars the two
new additions Margaret Bowman and
Janelle Monae ladies Congrats on this
dubious honor now let's move on to the
Best Actress category
wow what a crowded field so crowded it
may have led to some controversial mood
check it out I say Hailee Steinfeld
humor Sally Field Sally Field is my no
brainer
oh wait let me get a third vote so I
field for sure yeah Jennifer Lawrence
her passengers fat just kidding no love
for uh miss Portman I hear she did the
voice she did do the poison now I mean
ABN doesn't arrival is there any is
there any support for Amy Adams and
nocturnal animals her was just like like
like they just got a bunch of random
takes on other thing again when you just
put it to look Tracy Hinson is an easy
one I thought she was the best person in
that tire movie yeah I think so good put
her on the board all right
that's right GP husband on the board
Molly Shannon is really good and other
people for me it's very much for like Oh
comedian ended up being like a really
good dramatic actress I give it one on
Shannon I know Athena exactly I did and
I'm on the trailer I got a second and
yes I hear it's really good luck Joe
yeah that's a nice looking when our
levers have tomato put her on the Bob
Barker I mean under unity in this movie
look I remember to Amy Adams and end of
the matter
for most this is a trap of people at
focus this is it a for usage of system
we should really want to lipstick your
screen junkies nominees for Best Actress
are Amy Adams arrival Sally Field hello
my name is Doris taraji P Henson hidden
figures Molly Shannon other people and
Hailee Steinfeld age of seventeen
believe it or not none of these women
were nominated for Academy Awards this
year that's right five brand-new choices
and one of them was in a film that most
of us hadn't even seen just like the
real actor I'm not gonna lie a couple of
our choices might have been made just to
spite someone else
not because of actual great performances
our work did not get any easier let's
move on to the heated discussion we had
as we explored Best Actor I'm open to
people that went to nominated for a
while and as they want to but I thought
he was actually better in the nice guys
yeah Chris Pine from hell or high water
Oscar nominee is Andrew Garfield or
fiedel Mortensen here I put me going I
love deagle Mortensen Colin Farrell
beyond him I got him yeah he's up there
for me I did sell yes there's one that I
thought he was great no much yelling
taxiing acting yeah yeah yeah Denzel
doing Denzel is for Dylan uh our
nominated great Sonny for equality you
haven't in the movie the most adorable
kid you'll ever see you're adorable and
the kid from room yes I'll endorse
Ferrell and riddled I don't see the
doctor performance out of Ron Rhodes and
Deadpool oh he's already into it if we
can exploit the Academy system for
nominating things that people here are
good at and I'm going to discuss this
before he put in two great performances
in one year so I'm I'm gonna go behind
Godwin - okay
all right I got both in my head you
later like how that was really nice that
was one tough decision but here are your
final five nominees for Best Actor Colin
Farrell for the lobster
ryan gosling lala land sunny Pawar lyin
Ryan Reynolds Deadpool and Denzel
Washington Benson so only two nominees
were carried over from the actual Oscar
nomination Ryan Gosling and Denzel
Washington and I have a sneaking
suspicion that Ryan Reynolds only got
nominated because they agreed to help us
with the Deadpool on a trailer the [ __ ]
is that supposed to mean
see Ryan we told you would pay off next
up let's go behind the camera and take a
look at the deliberation next director I
want to put a woman on the list Kelly
Freeman Craig for edge of seventeen oh
yeah yeah that was a really well they
are you Directorate Wow
I'm going to go Telugu for arrival you
gotta put John carnea for sink yeah
pretty pretty good so anyone that we all
agree to go through I would get behind
Giselle Farrell yeah and bear Jenkins
Giselle Jenkin I get behind both those
ah we're going to go 12 around the mall
and I can argue
I will no III go with Chazelle because
he has a narrative story and this
choreography is a lot of heavy lifting
as a director avro Jungle Book just the
scope of what he attempted and pulled
off and then the top three building
Jenkins chisel you know go green room
it's a really good b-movie and I agree
Viggo what items you now join syllabus
obviously anything anyway all agree that
three should be taken seriously so I
think you put in Singh Street and model
man
well NH 17 so we would have gone into
three yeah yeah there it is I'm happy
with those I hope you kept track because
that was a lot of voting but here are
the final five nominee John Carney Singh
Street
Damien Chazelle lalala Kelly Freeman
Craig the edge of 17 Barry Jenkins
moonlight and
denis villeneuve arrival so for Best
Director three of the directors carried
over from the oscar-nomination
but we had two new entries the directors
of sing Street and the edge of seventeen
two smaller films - found themselves
some fans right here at Spring jump now
time for the big best motion picture and
the debate for this category was heated
people made boatsman switch votes and
alliances were formed and broken we
almost came to blows no he actually
didn't it was pretty friendly and fun
but it got a little heated and our job
was tough because we only made five
choices as opposed to the Academy
weapons nine Bob check it out oh god I
can already tell it's gonna be able to
hey let's do this
alright that's fiction could be the same
one what are how many are we laughs you
dominating here I what is that the thing
that we differ from the actual Oscars
you know they expanded it so they could
do more I think it's more fun and more
difficult to do when you suck at Oscars
I would nominate fences for Best Picture
person oh yeah their forces are great I
got nominated for Best Picture Mara pink
we all like Singh Street no no no let's
let it help us out you know what I'm
gonna go through most unique movie I saw
in 2016 I'm voting Swiss Re man because
it's just so weird and unique I sit in a
room every day with Spencer and he
doesn't like anything so him saying that
hell or high water was the second time
would be your tie praise I don't know
the hell are high waters did great no
okay great well you know I'm going to go
Deadpool just for the good fish yes for
the chimichangas I'm shocking to you all
and only has 100 people like that movie
I'm sorry Bay okay it was like fun I got
director I'm happy in fact I a four of
us say looking on the buff yes no
there's a lot about it might drop by ah
yeah I am I just beyond me I cannot
believe that no one here but me
they study under the 5s movies of the
year that's shocking so compelling so
inside baseball
olá actors blah blah blah I feel like
this is the backlash speaking I feel no
no no no I don't want to claim that I
was like
says no I didn't like it when it came
out I think don't think white did the
job that la LaLanne tried to do better
yeah it was more realistic for sure you
put Molly Shannon but having not seen
her movie you nominated for an Academy
Award but you hide the Solomons launch
it and in malla window go for it III I
feel like I'm gonna clearly that guy
just has a big Jazz boner and he just
wants to make jazz movies about jazz
great as well yeah wit life is a great I
think jazz happened that all right I'll
take my both of that bull and give us
all
oh I'll stick your gun-sling query on
Manchester by the see up there are you
taking a boat away the VOC that take
your Lowell in I was backed up of
Manchester all right let's move on to
mention you want to give this movie the
most depressing go nowhere where you
looking is a story of a sister by the
sea
Oh God like sucks oh my life still sucks
life sucks CN roll the credits I'll take
mine from Manchester and give it to oh
wow no we took your most checkered house
yeah five minute we've been chasing
boats all sides this is royal finalists
army man German yeah right whoo that was
a tough of you guys and I can tell you
truthfully Dan Merle left the studio and
drove straight to a movie theater
playing la-la-land
that's actual here are the screen
junkies nominees
arrival hell or high water
moonlight same street and swiss army man
so of our five choices
three of them were nominated by the
Academy two of them were brand-new
choices by us sing streets and with our
meters so there you have the screen
junkies nomination we left off some
heavy weights by the way no Meryl Streep
no Casey Affleck who a lot of people are
home frontrunner for Best Actor and two
major contenders for Best Picture
Manchester by the seats and Lala lambs
are singing the blues today what do you
think of our choice what would you have
included what would you take it off let
us know in the comment section below I
want to thank you for watching screen
junkies I'm Hal Rudnick hit me up on
Twitter bye bye then with us up in this
giant factory so let me get the first
without get in don't drop me oh don't
believe in Hewlett